i'll tell you this i watched the fight
uh
i watched the fight this weekend and i'm
gonna go on
look corey sandhagen
versus uh tuja dillashaw
and
look these men are both warriors
you know i i
am not anything like them i
am you know these these are first
class combatists
you know these men have i mean and i you
know
i've suffered from erectile dysfunction
you know these dudes have you know
i mean they're just damn made out of
viagra it almost seemed like they'll
just
i mean they'll just damn put your lights
out
they got almost like dicks in their arms
you know they're just so
uh virile you know they're warriors the
combatants
um if it were
you know archaic times or robin hood
whenever that was sixteen hundred
you know you'd have san hagen would be
like a he'd be a king or a young
king somewhere and i think
uh tuja would be a uh
he'd be uh you know uh
he almost has the villain role to me for
some reason
and i don't know why that is maybe it
could have been
you know because of the suspension
coming back from the suspension he had
that
you know he's got that um
[Music]
that's uh he's a little more slytherin
and i'm not you know no shade either of
these men they're both
you know these men would i mean these
men could tie me in a knot with their
damn tongue
you know these fellas would cherry stem
me up
so uh but anyway i'm watching the fight
and
i mean san hagen put that he put he he
hit him in the rafters real early
you know and he he really clipped him
and got a little bit of blood out of
them
not much but i would say probably half
cup
throughout the whole event quarter cup
maybe
um which might have given you the diet
but maybe
if you're if if i'm corey san hagen i
have the idea that i'm getting
maybe it gives me the idea that i'm
winning more that i'm it just
visually it looked like that so i could
know that maybe that would have been off
you had you had um san hagen landed more
strikes you know he hit him with more
opportunities i mean he was just damn
throwing just
you know he was out there like a damn
battle bot
now i think the part where it gets
tricky
is that dillashaw is that pressure bear
you know what i'm saying he's that honey
hunter man he's
the second you let him
the second you open that zoo cage he is
out there mauling people
whereas san hagen is more that sniper
you know he kind of works for the
electric company he'll climb up the pole
and kind of see what's going on and then
he'll
zap you you know
he's really that um you know that's kind
of how he is you know
uh but damn dillashaw's out there
beating the damn uh
diet coke out of a child's hand he don't
you know what i'm saying he's just
he's the mauler so i think
i could see it visually there's kind of
two different things going on you have
dillashaw controlling
you know we kind of held corey against
the cage he had that control time
you know that time of it was almost slow
dancing you almost want him to put a
song on
you know put on some garth brooks or put
on a little bit of uh
you know maybe some really slow kodak
black or something if he's ever done a
ballad
or some early uh
or some early bieber some early jb
you know throw that on but the controls
are like it's just kind of like
i don't know i feel like sometimes
you're just holding somebody there
now i know he did a lot of knees to him
he really need him up
you know we need him up like a damn you
know kind of like the way a armless man
would make a damn uh
would kind of prepare a doe or do veal
if you got somebody with no arms the way
they do veal it's just
you know what i'm saying they need that
damn little animal in a submission
until it's ready to you know be a damn
macaroni grill entree
but i just feel like and and so
you had san hagen uh you had dillasaw
pushed the bout
he pushed about he came at him but i
don't think there's anything wrong with
backing away
from a guy to get into the position that
you want the most
you know if a bee's coming at you
you don't just attack the beat you kind
of reposition yourself
you move around you might circle the
block
you may put a mannequin out there that's
dressed like you and then sneak around
watch the bee see what it's doing and
then come back at it
but i don't think there's anything wrong
with just
repositioning yourself if you look at
how what sandy hagan did
against uh frankie edgar's who i love
dear god man i wish he was my godfather
if i could be
you know if i could climb back in my
mother's vagina and you know email
frankie before i would see if he would
do that for me
but san hagen did that against edgar he
kind of just backed up and moved him
into position
so you have to respect that just because
a guy is kind of retreating
that can be strategy
so i thought it was really close
[Music]
i think it's interesting when a sport is
also a business
there's going to become moments where if
you let it be too close
that the business can
help determine what the future looks
like
and it's a great look for the uh weight
class it's a great look for
ufc um
you know dillashaw was
you know they kind of it almost felt
like
san hagen had to prove himself more than
dillashaw had to prove himself
so i don't know if some of the judges
went into it with uh you know with that
sort of
mindset in the beginning but i feel like
the outcome was better for the business
and also look what do i know nothing i'm
a one stripe white belt that hasn't been
in class in almost a month because i
my ribs kept getting fractured by women
and men and women
but um so i think that it was a great
it looks it's great for the business
suddenly you got dylan shaw's back in
there and
uh you know he's back in the in the bout
structure
so you're gonna get more fights out of
him san hagen's still young
you know he can you know he'll be able
to meander around in there before
uh you know he'll be able to you know
you could
insert him back in for that title shot
whenever
maybe you run it back um
i don't know i just don't see i see how
if i'm the business
if i'm the business i i then i give it
to dillashaw
but if i'm a judge i side with how
anthony smith said it you know
the lionhearted one he said it after the
show he said i had it 4-1
uh san hagen's and that's how i had it
man
i had sand higgins winning now brent and
child would disagree with me
but oh well
i don't have to agree with him all the
time if i don't want to or anyone
and look i don't know what i'm talking
about but
i believe i know what i saw and
i believe that corey sanhagan did enough
to win
so